MICHALE FEE: All right, let's
go ahead and get started.
So we're starting
a new topic today.
This is actually one of
my favorite lectures,
one of my favorite subjects
in computational neuroscience.
All right, so brief recap
of what we've been doing.
So we've been working on circuit
models of neural networks.
And we've been
working on what we
call a rate model,
in which we replaced
all the spikes of a
neuron with, essentially,
a single number
that characterizes
the rate at which
a neuron fires.
We introduced a simple
network in which
we have an input neuron
and an output neuron
with a synaptic connection
of weight w between them.
And that synaptic connection
leads to a synaptic input
that's proportional
to w times the firing
rate of the input neuron.
And then we talked about
how we can characterize
the output, the firing
rate of the output neuron,
as some nonlinear function
of the total input
to this output neuron.
We've talked about
different F-I curves.
We've talked about having
what's called a binary threshold
unit, which has zero firing
below some threshold.
And then actually, there
are different versions
of the binary threshold unit.
Sometimes the
firing rate is zero
for inputs below the threshold.
And in other models,
we use a minus 1.
And then a constant firing rate
of one above that threshold.
And we also talked
about linear neurons,
where we can write down the
firing rate of the output
neuron just as a weighted
sum of the inputs.
And remember that
these neurons are
kind of special in that they
can have negative firing
rates, which is not really
biophysically plausible,
but mathematically, it's very
convenient to have neurons
like this.
So we took this simple model
and we expanded it to the case
where we have many input
neurons and many output neurons.
So now we have a vector of input
firing rates, u, and a vector
of output firing rates, u.
And for the case
of linear neurons,
we talked about how
you can write down
the vector of firing
rates of the output neuron
simply as a matrix product of a
weight matrix times the vector
of input firing rates.
And we talked about how this
can produce transformations
of this vector of
input firing rates.
So in this high-dimensional
space of inputs,
we can imagine stretching
that input vector
along different directions to
amplify certain directions that
may be more important
than others.
We talked about how
you can do that,
stretch in arbitrary directions,
not just along the axes.
And we talked about
how that vector of--
that, sorry, matrix of weights
can produce a rotation.
So we can have
some set of inputs
where, let's say,
we have clusters
of different input
values corresponding
to different things.
And you can rotate that
to put certain features
in particular output neurons.
So now you can
discriminate one class
of objects from another
class of objects
by looking at just
one dimension and not
the whole
high-dimensional space.
So today, we're going to look
at a new kind of network called
a recurrent neural
network, where not
only do we have inputs
to our output neurons
from an input layer, but
we also have connections
between the neurons
in the output layer.
So these neurons in a recurrent
network talk to each other.
And that imbues some really cool
properties onto these networks.
So we're going to
develop the math
and describe how
these things work
to develop an intuition for
how recurrent networks respond
to their inputs.
We're going to get into
some of the computations
that recurrent networks can do.
They can act as amplifiers
in particular directions.
They can act as integrators, so
they can accumulate information
over time.
They can generate sequences.
They can act as
short-term memories
of either continuous variables
or discrete variables.
It's a very powerful kind
of circuit architecture.
And on top of that, in order to
describe these mathematically,
we're going to use all of
the linear algebra tools
that we've been
developing so far.
So, hopefully, a bunch of things
will kind of connect together.
OK, so mathematical description
of recurrent networks.
We're going to
talk about dynamics
in these recurrent
networks, and we're
going to start with
the very simplest kind
of recurrent network
called an autapse network.
Then we're going to extend
that to the general case
of recurrent connectivity.
And then we're going to
talk about how recurrent
networks store memories.
So we'll start talking about
a specific circuit models
for storing short-term memories.
And I'll touch on recurrent
networks for decision-making.
And this will kind of lead
into the last few lectures
of the class, where
we get into how
sort of specific cases of
looking at how networks
can store memories.
OK, mathematical description.
All right, so the first
thing that we need to do is--
the really cool thing
about recurrent networks
is that their activity
can evolve over time.
So we need to talk about
dynamics, all right?
The feed-forward networks
that we've been talking about,
we just put in an input.
It gets weighted by
synaptic strength,
and we get a firing
rate in the output,
just sort of instantaneously.
We've been thinking
of you put an input,
and you get an output.
In general, neural
networks don't do that.
You put an input, and
things change over time
until you settle at
some output, maybe,
or it starts doing something
interesting, all right?
So the time course
of the activity
becomes very
important, all right?
So neurons don't respond
instantaneously to inputs.
There are synaptic delays.
There are integration
of membrane potential.
Things change over time.
And a specific example of
this that we saw in the past
is that if you have
an input spike,
you can produce a postsynaptic
current that jumps up abruptly
as the synaptic
conductance turns on.
And then the
synaptic conductance
decays away as the
neurotransmitter unbinds
from the neurotransmitter
receptor,
and you get a synaptic current
that decays away over time, OK?
So that's a simple kind of time
dependence that you would get.
And that could lead
to time dependence
in the firing rate
of the output neuron.
OK, dendritic
propagation, membrane
time constant, other examples
of how things can take time
in a neural network.
All right, so we're
going to model
the firing rate of our output
neuron in the following way.
If we have an input
firing rate that's zero
and then steps up to some
constant and then steps down,
we're going to model the output,
the firing rate of the output
neuron, using exactly the
same kind of first order
linear differential
equation that we've
been using all along for
the membrane potential,
for the Hodgkin-Huxley
gating variables.
The same kind of differential
equation that you've
seen over and over again.
So that's the differential
equation we're going to use.
We're going to say that the
time derivative of the firing
rate of the output neuron
times the time constant
is just equal to minus the
firing rate of the output
non plus v infinity.
And so you know that the
solution to this equation
is that the firing rate
of the output neuron
will just relax exponentially
to some new v infinity.
And the v infinity
that we're going to use
is just this non-linear function
times the weighted input
to our neuron.
So we're going to take the
formalism that we developed
for our feed-forward
networks to say,
what is the firing
rate of the output
neuron as a function
of the inputs?
And we're going to use
that firing rate that we've
been using before as the
v infinity for our network
with dynamics.
Any questions about that?
All right, so that becomes
our differential equation now
for this recurrent
network, all right?
So it's just a first order
linear differential equation,
where the v infinity, the steady
state firing rate of the output
neuron, is just this nonlinear
function times the weighted sum
of all the inputs.
All right, and actually, for
most of what we do today,
we're going to just take
the case of a linear neuron.
All right.
So this I've already said.
This I've already said.
And actually, what I'm doing
here is just extending this.
So this was the case for
a single output neuron
and a single input neuron.
What we're doing now is
we're just extending this
to the case where we have
a vector of input neurons
with a firing rate represented
by a firing rate vector u,
and a vector of output
neurons with a fine rate
vector v. And we're just going
to use this same differential
equation, but we're going to
write it in vector notation.
So each one of
these output neurons
has an equation
like this, and we're
going to combine them all
together into a single vector.
Does that make sense?
All right, so there
is our vector notation
of the activity in
this recurrent network.
Sorry, I forgot to put the
recurrent connections in there.
So the time dependence
is really simple
in this feed-forward
network, right?
So in a feed-forward
network, the dynamics
just look like this.
But in a recurrent
network, this thing
can get really interesting and
start doing interesting stuff.
All right, so let's add
recurrent connections now
and add these recurrent
connections to our equation.
So in addition to
this weight matrix
w that describes the
connections from the input
layer to the output
layer, we're going
to have another
weight matrix that
describes the connections
between the neurons
in the output layer.
And this weight
matrix, of course,
has to be able to
describe a connection
from any one of these neurons
to any other of these neurons.
And so this weight
matrix is going
to be a function of the
postsynaptic neuron,
the weight--
the synaptic strength
is going to be
a function of the postsynaptic
neuron and the presynaptic--
the identity of the
postsynaptic neuron
and the identity of
the presynaptic neuron.
Does that make sense?
OK, so there are
two kinds of input--
a feed-forward input
from the input layer
and a recurrent input due to
connections within the output
layer.
Any questions about that?
OK, so there is the
equation now that
describes the time rate
of change of the firing
rates in the output layer.
It's just this first order
linear differential equation.
And the infinity is just
this non-linear function
of the inputs, of the net input
to this neuron, to each neuron.
And the net input to
this set of neurons
is a contribution from
the feed-forward inputs,
given by this weight matrix
w, and this contribution
from the recurrent inputs,
given by this weight matrix, m.
So that is the crux
of it, all right?
So I want to make sure that
we understand where we are.
Does anybody have any
questions about that?
No?
All right, then I'll push ahead.
All right, so what is this?
So we've seen this before.
This product of
this weight matrix
times this vector of
input firing rates
just looks like this.
You can see that the input to
this neuron, this first output
neuron, is just the dot
product of these weights
onto the first
neuron and the dot
product of that vector of
weights, that row of the weight
matrix, with the vector
of input firing rates.
And the feed-forward
contribution to this neuron
is just the dot product of that
row weight of this input weight
matrix with the vector of
input firing rates, and so on.
If we look at the recurrent
input to these neurons,
the recurrent input
to this first neuron
is just going to
be the dot product
of this row of the
recurrent weight matrix
and the vector of firing
rates in the output layer.
The recurrent inputs
to the second neuron
is going to be the dot product
of this row of the weight
matrix and the vector
of firing rates.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I guess
I'm a little confused,
because I thought it was
from A. Oh, to A. OK.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
it's always post, pre.
Post, pre in a weight matrix.
That's because we're
usually writing
down these vectors the way that
I'm defining this notation.
This vector is a column
matrix, a column vector.
All right, so we're going
to make one simplification
to this.
When we work with the
recurrent networks,
we're usually going to
simplify this input.
And rather than write down this
complex feed-forward component,
writing this out as
this matrix product,
we're just going to
simplify the math.
And rather than carry
around this w times u,
we're just going to replace
that with a vector of inputs
onto each one of
those neurons, OK?
So we're just going to pretend
that the input to this neuron
is just coming
from one input, OK?
And the input to
this neuron is coming
from another single input.
And so we're just going to
replace that feed-forward input
onto this network
with this vector h.
So that's the
equation that we're
going to use moving
forward, all right?
Just simplifies
things a little bit so
we're not carrying
around this w u.
So now, that's our
equation that we're
going to use to describe
this recurrent network.
This is a system of
coupled equations.
What does that mean?
You can see that the time
derivative of the firing
rate of this first neuron
is given by a contribution
from the input layer
and a contribution
from other neurons
in the output layer.
So the time rate of
change of this neuron
depends on the activity
in all the other neurons
in the network.
And the time rate of
change in this neuron
depends on the activity
of all the other neurons
in the network.
So that's a set of
coupled equations.
And that, in general, can be--
you know, it's not obvious,
when you look at it,
what the solution is, all right?
So we're going to develop the
tools to solve this equation
and get some intuition about
how networks like this behave
in response to their inputs.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is to simplify this network
to the case of linear neurons.
So we don't have--
so the neurons just fire.
Their firing rate is just
linear with their input.
And so that's the equation
for the linear case.
All we've done is
we've just gotten rid
of this non-linear function f.
All right, so now let's
take a very simple case
of a recurrent network
and use this equation
to see how it
behaves, all right?
So the simplest case
of a recurrent network
is the case where the recurrent
connections within this layer
are given by--
the weight matrix is given
by a diagonal matrix.
Now, what does
that correspond to?
What that corresponds to is
this neuron making a connection
onto itself with a synapse of
weight lambda one, right there.
And that kind of
recurrent connection
of a neuron onto itself
is called an autapse,
like an auto synapse.
And we're going to put
one of those autapses
on each one of these
neurons in our output layer,
in our recurrent layer.
So now we can write
down the equation
for this network, all right?
And what we're going to
do is simply replace--
sorry, let me just bring
up that equation again.
Sorry, there's the equation.
And we're simply going to
replace this weight matrix
m, this recurrent weight matrix,
with that diagonal matrix
that I just showed you.
So there it is.
So that time rate of change of
this vector of output neurons
is just minus v plus this
diagonal matrix times
[INAUDIBLE] plus the inputs.
So now you can see
that if we write out
the equation separately for each
one of these output neurons--
so here it is in
vector notation.
We can just write that out for
each one of our output neurons.
So there's a separate
equation like this
for each one of these neurons.
But you can see that
these are all uncoupled.
So we can understand how
this network responds just
by studying this equation
for one of those neurons.
OK, so let's do that.
We have an independent equation.
The firing rate change--
the time derivative of the
firing rate of neuron one
depends only on the
firing rate of neuron one.
It doesn't depend on
any other neurons.
As you can see,
it's not connected
to any of the other neurons.
OK, so let's write
this equation.
And let's see what that
equation looks like.
So we're going to rewrite
this a little bit.
We're just going to factor
out the va all right here.
This parameter,
1 minus lambda a,
controls what kind of
solutions this equation has.
And there are three different
cases that we need to consider.
We need to consider
the case where
1 minus lambda is greater
than zero, equal to zero,
or less than zero.
Those three different values of
that parameter 1 minus lambda
give three different kinds of
solutions to this equation.
We're going to
start with the case
where lambda is less than one.
And if lambda is less than
1, then this term right
here is greater than zero.
If we do that, then we
can rewrite this equation
as follows.
We're going to divide both
sides of this equation
by 1 minus lambda, and
that's what we have here.
And you can see that this
equation starts looking
very familiar, very simple.
We have a first order linear
differential equation, where
we have a time constant here,
tau over 1 minus lambda,
and a v infinity here, which is
the input, the effective input
onto that neuron, divided
by 1 minus lambda.
So that's tau dv dt equals
minus v plus v infinity.
But now you can see
that the time constant
and the v infinity
depend on lambda,
depend on the strength of
that connection, all right?
And the solution to that we've
seen before, to this equation.
It's just exponential
relaxation toward v infinity.
OK, so here's our v infinity.
There's our tau.
True for the case
of lambda between--
let's just look at these
solutions for the case
of lambda between zero and one.
So I'm going to plot v as a
function of time when we have
an input that goes from zero
and then steps up and then
is held constant.
All right, so let's look at
the case of lambda equals zero.
So this lambda zero
means there's no autapse.
It's just not connected.
So you can see
that, in this case,
the solution is very simple.
It's just exponential relaxation
toward infinity. v infinity
is just given by h, the
input, and tau is just
the original tau,
1 minus 0, right?
So it's just exponential
relaxation to h.
That make sense?
And it relaxes with a
time constant tau, tau m.
We're going to now turn up
the synapse a little bit
so that it has a
little bit of strength.
You see that what happens
when lambda is 0.5,
that v infinity gets bigger.
v infinity goes to 2h.
Why?
Because it's h divided
by 1 minus 0.5.
So it's h over 0.5, so 2h.
And what happens to
the time constant?
Well, it becomes two tau.
All right, and if we make
lambda equal to 0.3--
sorry, 0.66.
We turn it up a little bit.
You can see that the response
of this neuron gets even bigger.
So you can see that
what's happening
is that when we start
letting this neuron feed back
to itself, positive feedback,
the response of the neuron
to a fixed input--
the input is the same
for all of those.
The response of the
neuron gets bigger.
And so having positive feedback
of that neuron onto itself
through an autapse just
amplifies the response
of this neuron to its input.
Now, let's consider
the case where--
so positive feedback
amplifies the response.
And what also does it do?
It slows the response down.
The time constants are
getting longer, which
means the response is slower.
All right, let's look
at what happens when
the lambdas are less than zero.
What does lambda less than
zero correspond to here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, which
is, in neurons, what
does that correspond to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Inhibition.
So this neuron, when
you put an input in,
it tries to activate the neuron.
But that neuron inhibits itself.
So what do you think's
going to happen?
So positive feedback
made the response bigger.
Here, the neuron is kind
of inhibiting itself.
So what's going to happen?
You put in that same
h that we had before,
what's going to happen
when we have inhibition?
AUDIENCE: Response
is [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: The response
is going to be smaller.
MICHALE FEE: The response will
just be smaller, that's right.
So let's look at that.
So here's firing
rate of this neuron
is a function of time
for a step input.
You can see for a
lambda equals zero,
we're going to respond
with an amount h.
But if we put in--
in a time constant tau.
If we put in a lambda
of negative one--
that means you put
this input in--
that neuron starts
inhibiting itself,
and you can see the
response is smaller.
But another thing
that's real interesting
is that you can see that
the response of the neuron
is actually faster.
So if the feedback-- if
the lambda is minus one,
you can see that v infinity
is h over 1 minus negative 1.
So it's h over 2.
All right, and so on.
The more we turn up that
inhibition, the more
suppressed the
neuron is, the weaker
the response that
neuron is to its input,
but the faster it is.
So negative feedback suppresses
the response of the neuron
and speeds up the response.
OK, now, there's one other
really important thing
about recurrent networks
in this regime, where
this lambda is less than one.
And that is that
the activity always
relaxes back to zero when
you turn the input off.
OK, so you put a step
input in, the neuron
responds, relaxing exponentially
to sum of v infinity.
But when you turn the
input off, the network
relaxes back to zero, OK?
So now let's go to
the more general case
of recurrent connections.
Oh, and first, I
just want to show you
how we actually show graphically
how a neuron responds--
sorry, how one of
these networks respond.
And a typical way
that we do that is we
plot the firing rate of one
neuron versus the firing
rate of another neuron.
That's called a
state-space trajectory.
And we plot that response
as a function of time
after we put in an input.
So we can put an input in
described as some vector.
So we put in some h1
and h2, and we then
plot the response
of the neuron--
the response of the network
in this output state space.
So let me show you an example
of what that looks like.
So here is the output
of this little network
for different kinds of inputs.
So Daniel made this nice
little movie for us.
Here, you can see that if you
put an input into neuron one,
neuron one responds.
If you put a negative
input into neuron one,
the neuron goes negative.
If you put an input into neuron
two, the neuron responds.
And if you put a negative input
into neuron two, it responds.
Now, why did it respond
bigger in this direction than
in this direction?
AUDIENCE: That's [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Because neuron one had--
AUDIENCE: Positive?
MICHALE FEE: Positive feedback.
And neuron two had
negative feedback.
So neuron one, this neuron
one, amplified its input
and gave a big response.
Neuron two suppressed the
response to its input,
and so it had a weak response.
Let's look at another
interesting case.
Let's put an input
into these neurons--
not one at a time,
but simultaneously.
So now we're going to put an
input into both neurons one
and two simultaneously.
It's like Spirograph.
Did you guys play
with Spirograph?
It's kind of weird, right?
It's like making little
butterflies for spring.
So why does the output--
why does the response
of this neuron
to an input, positive input to
both h1 and h2, look like this?
Let's just break this down into
one of these little branches.
We start at zero.
We put an input into h1
and h2, and the response
goes quickly like this and
then relaxes up to here.
So why is that?
Lena?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
there was [INAUDIBLE] and then
because it's negative,
it's shorter.
MICHALE FEE: Yup.
The response in the v2
direction is weak but fast.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHALE FEE: So it
goes up quickly.
And then the response
in the v1 direction is?
AUDIENCE: Slow, but [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Good.
That's it.
It's slow, but [AUDIO OUT].
It's amplified in this
direction, suppressed
in this direction.
But the response is fast
this way and slow this way.
So it traces this out.
Now, when you turn the input
off, again, it relaxes.
v2 relaxes quickly back to
zero, and v1 relaxes slowly
back to zero.
So it kind of traces out
this kind of hysteretic loop.
It's not really hysteresis.
Then it's exactly
mirror image when
you put in a negative input.
And when you put in h1
positive and v1 negative,
it just looks like
a mirror image.
All right, so any
questions about that?
Yes, Lena?
AUDIENCE: If there was nothing,
like no kind of amplified
or [INAUDIBLE],, would it
just be like a [INAUDIBLE]??
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
so if you took out
the recurrent connections, what
would what would it look like?
AUDIENCE: An x?
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, the output--
so let's say that you just
literally set those to zero.
Then the response will be
the identity matrix, right?
You get the output as
a function of input.
Let's just go back
to the equation.
Can always, always
get the answer
by looking at the equation.
Too many animations.
No, it's a very good question.
Here we go.
There it is right there.
So you're asking about-- let's
just ask about the steady state
response.
So we can set dv
dt equal to zero.
And you're asking, what is v?
And you're saying, let's
set lambda to zero, right?
We're going to set all these
diagonal elements to zero.
And so now v equals h.
OK, great question.
Now, let's go to the case
of fully recurrent networks.
We've been working with
this simplified case of just
having neurons have autapses.
And the reason we've been doing
that is because the answer
you get for the autapse
kind of captures
almost all the intuition
that you need to have.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to take a fully
recurrent neural network,
and we're going to do a
mathematical trick that
just turns it into
an autapse network.
And the answer for the
fully recurrent network
is just going to be just as
simple as what you saw here.
All right, so let's do that.
Let's take this fully
recurrent network.
Our weight matrix m now,
instead of just having
diagonal elements, also
has off-diagonal elements.
And I'll say that one
of the things that we're
going to do today is just
consider the simplest
case of this fully
recurrent network, where
the connections are symmetric,
where a connection from v1
to v2 is equal to the connection
from v2 to v1, all right?
We're going to do that
because that's the next thing
to do to build our
intuition, and it's
also mathematically simpler
than the fully general case, OK?
So we saw how the
behavior of this network
is very simple if m is diagonal.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take this
arbitrary matrix m,
and we're going to
just make it diagonal.
So let's do that.
So we're going to rewrite
our weight matrix m as--
so we're going to rewrite m
in this form, where this phi--
sorry, where this lambda
is a diagonal matrix.
So we're going to
take this network
with recurrent connections
between different neurons
in the network, and we're
going to transform it
into sort of an equivalent
network that just has autapses.
So how do we write
m in this form,
with a rotation matrix
times a diagonal matrix
times a rotation matrix?
We just solve this
eigenvalue equation, OK?
Does that make sense?
We're just going to do
exactly the same thing
we did in PCA, where we
find the covariance matrix.
And we rewrote the
covariance matrix like this.
Now we're going to
take a weight matrix
of this recurrent
network, and we're
going to rewrite it in
exactly the same way.
So that process is called
diagonalizing the weight
matrix.
So the elements of lambda
here are the eigenvalues of m.
And the columns of the phi
are the eigenvectors of m.
And we're going to use these
quantities, these elements,
to build a new network that
has the same properties
as our recurrent network.
So let me just show
you how we do that.
So remember that what
this eigenvalue--
this is an eigenvalue equation
written in matrix notation.
What this means is this is set
of eigenvalues equations that
have-- it's a set of
n eigenvalue equations
like this, where
there's one of these
for each neuron in the network.
OK, so let me just
go through that.
OK, so here's the
eigenvalue equation.
If M is a symmetric matrix,
then the eigenvalues are real
and phi is a rotation matrix.
And the eigenvectors give us
an orthogonal basis, all right?
So everybody remember this
from a few lectures ago?
If M is symmetric--
and this is why
we're going to, at
this point on, consider
just the case where
M is symmetric,
then the eigenvectors, the
columns of that matrix phi,
give us an orthogonal set of
vectors and their unit vectors.
So it satisfies this
orthonormal condition.
And phi transpose phi is
an identity matrix, which
means phi is a rotation matrix.
OK, so now what we're
going to do is rewrite.
The first thing we're going
to do to use this trick
to rewrite our
matrix, our network,
is to rewrite the
vector of firing rates v
in this new basis.
What are we going to do?
Well take the vector and
all we're going to do
is to rewrite that vector
in this new basis set.
We're just going to do a change
of basis of our firing rate
vector into a new
basis set that's
given by the columns of phi.
Another way of saying
it is that we're
going to rotate this firing rate
vector v using the phi rotation
matrix.
So we're going to project v
onto each one of those new basis
vectors.
So there's v in
the standard basis.
There's our new
basis, f1 and f2.
We're going to project
v onto f1 and f2
and write down that scalar
projection, c1 and c2.
So we're going to write down
the scalar projection of v
onto each one of
those basis vectors.
So we can write
that c sub alpha--
that's the alpha-th component--
is just v dot the
alpha-th basis vector.
So now we can express v
as a linear combination
in this new basis.
So it's c1 times f1 plus
c2 times f2 plus c3--
that's supposed to be a three--
times f3 and so on.
And of course, remember,
we're doing all of this
because we want to
understand the dynamics.
So these things
are time dependent.
So v is v changes in time.
We're not going to be changing
our basis vectors in time.
So if we want to write
down a time dependent v,
it's really these
coefficients that
are changing in time, right?
Does that make sense?
So we can now write our vector
v, our firing rate vector,
as a sum of contributions in
all these different directions
corresponding to the new basis.
And each one of
those coefficients, c
is just the time dependent
v projected onto one
of those basis vectors.
And questions?
No?
OK.
And remember, we can write
that in matrix notation using
this formalism that we developed
in the lecture on basis sets.
So v is just phi c, and c
is just phi transpose v.
So we're just taking
this vector v,
and we're rotating it
into a new basis set,
and we can rotate it back.
All right, so now
what we're going to do
is we're going to take this v
expressed in this new basis set
and were going to rewrite our
equation in that new basis set.
Watch this.
This is so cool.
All right, you ready?
We're going to take this, and
we're to plug it into here.
So dv dt is phi dc dt.
V is just phi c.
v is phi c, and
h doesn't change.
So now what is that?
Do you remember?
AUDIENCE: Phi [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: Right.
We got phi as the solution
to the eigenvalue equation.
What was the
eigenvalue equation?
The eigenvalue equation was
m phi equals phi lambda.
So the phi here,
this rotation matrix,
is the solution to this
equation, all right?
So we're given m,
and we're saying
we're going to find
a phi and a lambda
such that we can write m
phi is equal to phi lambda.
So when we take that matrix m
and we run eig on it in Matlab,
Matlab sends us back a phi and
a lambda such that this equation
is true.
So literally, we can
take the weight matrix
m stick it into Matlab,
and get a phi and a lambda
such that m phi is
equal to phi lambda.
So m phi is equal to what?
Phi lambda.
That becomes this.
Now, all of a sudden, this
thing is just going to simplify.
So how would we
simplify this equation?
We can get rid of all of these
things, all of these phi's,
by doing what?
How do you get rid of phi's?
AUDIENCE: Multiply
[INAUDIBLE] phi transpose.
MICHALE FEE: You multiply
by phi transpose, exactly.
So we're going to multiply
each term in this equation
by phi transpose.
So what do you have?
Phi transpose phi, phi transpose
phi, phi transpose phi.
What is phi transpose
phi equal to?
The identity matrix.
Because it's a rotation
matrix, phi transpose
is just the inverse of phi.
So phi inverse phi is just
equal to the identity matrix.
And all those things disappear.
And you're left
with this equation--
tau dc dt equals minus c
plus lambda c plus h, hf.
And what is hf?
hf is just h rotated
into the new basis set.
So this is the equation
for a recurrent network
with just autapses,
which we just understood.
We just wrote down what
the solution is, right?
And we plotted it for
different values of lambda.
So now let's just look at
what some of these look like.
So we've rewritten our weight
matrix in a new basis set.
We've rebuilt our network
and a new basis set,
in a rotated basis set
where everything simplifies.
So we've taken this
complicated network
with recurrent connections
and we've rewritten it
in a new network, where
each of these neurons
in our new network
corresponds to what's
called a mode of the
fully recurrent network.
So the activities c alpha c1
and c2 of the network modes
represent kind of an activity
in a linear combination
of these neurons.
So we're going to go
through what that means now.
So the first thing I want
to do is just calculate
what the steady state
response is in this neuron.
And I'll just do
it mathematically,
and then I'll show you what
it looks like graphically.
So there's our original
network equation.
We've rewritten it a set
of differential equations
for the modes of this network.
I'm just rewriting this
by putting an I here,
minus I times c.
That's the only
change I made here.
I just rewrote it like this.
Let's find a steady state.
So we're going to set
dc dt equal to zero.
We're going to ask, what
is c in steady state?
So we're going to call
that c infinity, all right?
I minus lambda times c infinity
equals phi transpose h.
OK, don't panic.
It's all going to be
very simple in a second.
c infinity is just I minus
lambda inverse phi transpose h.
But I is diagonal.
Lambda is diagonal.
So I minus lambda
inverse is just the--
it's a diagonal matrix with
these elements with one
over all those
diagonal elements.
Now let's calculate v
infinity. v infinity
is just phi times v infinity.
So here, we're multiplying
on the left by phi.
That's just v infinity.
So v infinity is just this.
So what is this?
This just says v
infinity is some matrix--
it's a rotated stretch matrix--
times the input.
So v infinity is just
this matrix times h.
And now let's look
at what that is.
v infinity is a matrix times h.
We're going to call that g.
v infinity is a gain matrix.
We're going to think of that
as a gain times the input.
So it's just a matrix
operation on the input.
This matrix has exactly
the same eigenvectors as m.
And the eigenvalues are
just 1 over 1 minus lambda.
Hang in there.
So what this means is that
if an input is parallel
to one of the eigenvectors
of the weight matrix,
that means the output is
parallel to the input.
So if the input is
in the direction
of one of the eigenvectors,
v infinity is g times f.
But g times f--
f is an eigenvector
v. And what that means
is that v infinity is parallel
to f with a scaling factor
1 over 1 minus lambda.
All right?
So hang in there.
I'm going to show you
what this looks like.
So in steady state, the output
will be parallel to the input
if the input is in
the direction of one
of the eigenvectors
of the network.
So if the input is in
the direction of one
of the eigenvectors
of the network,
that means you're activating
only one mode of the network.
And only that one mode responds,
and none of the other modes
respond.
The response of
the network will be
in the direction of
that input, and it
will be amplified or
suppressed by this gain factor.
And the time constant will
also be increased or decreased
by that factor.
So now let's look at--
so I just kind of whizzed
through a bunch of math.
Let's look at what this
looks like graphically
for a few simple cases.
And then I think it will
become much more clear.
Let's just look at
a simple network,
where we have two neurons
with an excitatory connection
from neuron one to neuron
two, an excitatory connection
from neuron two to neuron one.
And we're going to
make that weight 0.8.
OK, so what is the weight
matrix M look like?
Just tell me what the
entries are for M.
AUDIENCE: Does it
not have the autapse?
MICHALE FEE: No, so
there's no connection
of any of these neurons
onto themselves.
AUDIENCE: So you have,
like, zeros on the diagonal.
MICHALE FEE: Zeros
on the diagonal.
Good.
AUDIENCE: All the diagonals.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Like that?
Good.
Connection from neuron
one to itself is zero.
The connection from
post, pre is row, column.
So onto neuron one
from neuron two is 0.8.
Onto neuron two from
neuron one is 0.8.
And neuron two onto
neuron two is zero.
So now we are just going to
diagonalize this weight matrix.
We're going to find the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
The eigenvectors are
the columns of phi.
And the eigenvalues are the
diagonal elements of lambda.
Let's take a look at what
those eigenvectors are.
So this vector here is f1.
This vector here is
another eigenvector, f2.
And how did I get this?
How did I get this from this?
How would you do that?
If I gave you this matrix,
how would you find phi?
AUDIENCE: Eig M.
MICHALE FEE: Good,
eig of M. Now,
remember in the
last lecture when
we were talking about some
simple cases of matrices
that are really easy to
find the eigenvectors of?
If you have a symmetric matrix,
where the diagonal elements are
equal to each other,
the eigenvectors
are always 45 degrees
here and 45 degrees there.
And the eigenvalues are just the
diagonal elements plus or minus
the off-diagonal elements.
So the eigenvalues here
are 0.8 and minus 0.8.
All right, so those are the two
eigenvectors of this matrix,
of this network.
Those are the modes
of the network.
Notice that one of the modes
corresponds to neuron one
and neuron two firing together.
The other mode corresponds
to neuron one and neuron
two firing with opposite sign--
minus one, one.
So the lambda-- the diagonal
elements of the lambda matrix
are the eigenvalues.
They're 0.8 and minus
0.8, a plus or minus b.
Now, this gain
factor, what this says
is that if I have an input
in the direction of f1,
the response is going to
be amplified by a gain.
And remember, we just derived,
on the previous slide,
that that gain factor
is just 1 over 1
minus the eigenvalue
for that eigenvector.
In this case, the eigenvalue
for mode one is 0.8.
So 1 over 1 minus 0.8 is 5.
So the gain in this
direction is 5.
The gain for an input
in this direction
is 1 over 1 minus negative
0.8, which is 1 over 1.8.
Does that makes sense?
OK, let's keep going,
because I think
it will make even
more sense once we
see how the network
responds to its inputs.
So zero input.
Now we're going to put an input
in the direction of this mode
one.
And you can see the
mode responds a lot.
Put a negative input
in, it responds a lot.
If we put a mode input in this
direction or this direction,
the response is suppressed
by an amount of about 0.5.
Because here, the gain is small.
Here, the gain is big.
So you see what's happening?
This network looks just
like an autapse network,
but where we've taken this
input and output space and just
rotated it into a new coordinate
system, into this new basis.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why did it
kind of loop around
on the one side [INAUDIBLE]?
MICHALE FEE: OK, it's because
these things are relaxing
exponentially back to zero.
And we got a little
bit impatient
and started the next input
before it had quite gone away.
OK, good question.
It's just that if you really
wait for a long time for it
to settle, then the movie
just takes a long time.
But maybe it would
be better to do that.
So input this way and this
way lead to a large response,
because those inputs activate
mode one, which has a big gain.
Inputs in this direction
and this direction
have a small response,
because they activate
mode two, which has small gain.
But notice that when
you activate mode one--
when you put an input
in this direction,
it only activates mode one.
And it doesn't activate
mode two at all.
If you put an input
in this direction,
then it only activates
mode two, and it doesn't
activate mode one at all.
So it's just like the
autapse network, but rotated.
So now let's do the case
where we have an input that
activates both modes.
So let's say we put an
input in this direction.
What does that direction
correspond to h up.
What is that input mean
here in terms of h1 and h2?
Let's say we just put
an input-- remember,
this is a plot on
axes h1 versus h2.
So this input
vector h corresponds
to just putting an input
on h2, into this neuron.
So you can see that when we
put an input in this direction,
we're activating--
that input has a projection
onto mode one and mode two.
So we're activating both modes.
You can see that the
input h has a projection
onto f1 and projection onto f2.
So what you do is--
well, here, I'm just showing
you what the steady state
response is mathematically.
Let me just show you
what that looks like.
What this says is that if we
put an h in this direction,
it's going to activate
a little bit of mode one
with a big gain and a
little bit of mode two
with a very small gain.
And so the steady state response
will be the sum of those two.
It'll be up here.
So the steady state response
to this input in this direction
is going to be over here.
Why?
Because that input activates
mode one and mode two both.
But the response
of mode one is big,
and the response of mode
two is really small.
And so the steady
state response is
going to be way
over here because
of the big response, the
amplified response of mode two,
which is in this direction, OK?
So when we put an
input straight up,
the response of
the network's going
to be all the way over here.
How is it going to get there?
Let's take a look.
We're going to put an input--
sorry, that was first
in this direction.
Now let's see what
happens when we
put an input in this direction.
You can see the response is
really big along the mode one
direction, in this
direction, and it's
really small in this direction.
So input up in the upward
direction onto just this neuron
produces a large
response in mode,
which is this way, and
a very small response
in mode two, which is this way.
The response in mode two is
very fast, because the lambda,
the 1 over 1 minus
lambda, is small,
which makes the
time constant faster
and the response smaller.
So, again, it's just
like the response
of the autapse
network, but rotated
into a new coordinate system.
All right, any
questions about that?
So you can see we basically
understood everything
we needed to know about
recurrent networks
just by understanding simple
networks with just autapses.
And all these more
complicated networks
are just nothing
but rotated versions
of the response of a
network with just autapses.
Any questions about that?
OK, let's do another
network now where
we have inhibitory connections.
That's called mutual inhibition.
And let's make that
inhibition minus 0.8.
The weight matrix is just
zeros on the diagonals,
because there's no autapse here.
And minus 0.8 on
the off-diagonals.
What are the eigenvectors for
this matrix, for this network?
AUDIENCE: The same.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
because the diagonal
elements are equal
to each other,
and the off-diagonal elements
are equal to each other.
It's a symmetric network
with equal diagonal elements.
The eigenvectors are
always at 45 degrees.
And what are the eigenvalues?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Well,
the two numbers
are going to be the same.
It's zero plus and minus 0.8,
plus and minus negative 0.8,
which is just 0.8
and minus 0.8, right?
Good.
So the eigenvalues are
just 0.8 and minus 0.8.
But the eigenvalues correspond
to different eigenvectors.
So now the eigenvalue
mode in the 1,
1 direction is now
minus 0.8, which
means it's suppressing the
response in this direction.
And the eigenvalue for the
eigenvector in the minus 1,
1 direction is now
close to 1, which
means that mode has a lot
of recurrent feedback.
And so its response in this
direction is going to be big.
It's going to be amplified.
So unlike the case where we had
positive recurrent synapses,
where we had amplification
in this direction, now
we're going to
have amplification
in this direction.
Does that make sense?
Think of it this way--
if we go back to
this network here,
you can see that when
these two neurons--
when this neuron is active, it
tends to activate this neuron.
And when this
neuron is activate,
it tends to activate
that neuron.
So this network, if you were to
activate one of these neurons,
it tends to drive the
other neuron also.
And so the activity of those two
neurons likes to go together.
When one is big, the
other one wants to be big.
And that's why there's a lot
of gain in this direction.
Does that make sense?
With these recurrent
excitatory connections,
it's hard to make
this neuron fire
and make that neuron not fire.
And that's why the response is
suppressed in this direction,
OK?
With this network, when
this neuron is active,
it's trying to
suppress that neuron.
When that neuron has
positive firing rate,
it's trying to make that neuron
have a negative firing rate.
When that neuron is
negative, it tries
to make that one go positive.
And so this network
likes to have
one firing positive and the
other neuron going negative.
And so that's what happens.
What you find is that if you put
an input into the first neuron,
it tends to suppress the
activity in the second neuron,
in v2.
If you put neuron
into neuron two,
it tends to suppress
the activity,
or make v1 go negative.
So it's, again, exactly
like the autapse network,
but just, in this case, rotated
minus 45 degrees instead
of plus 45 degrees, OK?
Any questions about that?
All right.
So now let's talk about how--
yes, Linda?
AUDIENCE: So we just did, those
were all symmetric matrices,
right?
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
can we not do this strategy
if it's not symmetric?
MICHALE FEE: You can do it
for non-symmetric matrices,
but non-symmetric
matrices start doing
all kinds of other
cool stuff that
is a topic for another day.
So symmetric matrices
are special in that they
have very simple dynamics.
They just relax to a
steady state solution.
Weight matrices that are
not symmetric, or even
anti-symmetric, tend to
do really cool things
like oscillating.
And we'll get to that in
another lecture, all right?
OK, so now let's talk about
using recurrent networks
to store memories.
So, remember, all of
the cases we've just
described, all of the
networks we've just described,
had the properties that the
lambdas were less than one.
So what we've been
looking at are
networks for which
lambda is less than one
and they're symmetric
weight matrices.
So that was kind
of a special case,
but it's a good case
for building intuition
about what goes on.
But now we're going
to start branching out
into more interesting behavior.
So let's take a look at what
happens to our equation.
This is now our equation
different modes of a network.
What happens to this equation
when lambda is actually
equal to one?
So when lambda is equal to one,
this term goes to zero, right?
So we can just cross this
out and rewrite our equation
as tau dc dt equals f1 f dot h.
So what is this?
What does that look like?
What's the solution to c for
this differential equation?
Does this exponentially
relax toward a v infinity?
What is v infinity here?
It's not even defined.
If you set dc dt equal to
zero, there's not even a c
to solve for, right?
So what is this?
The derivative of c
is just equal to--
if we put in an input
that's constant, what is c?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: This is
an integrator, right?
This c, the solution
to this equation,
is that c is the
integral of this input.
c is some initial c plus
the integral over time.
So if we have an input--
and again, what
we're plotting here
is the activity of one of
the modes of our network, c1,
which is a function
of the projection
of the input along the
eigenvector of mode one.
So we're going to plot h, which
is just how much the input
overlaps with mode one.
And as a function of time,
let's start at one equals zero.
What will this look like?
This will just
increase linearly.
And then what happens?
What happens here?
Raymundo?
AUDIENCE: R just stays constant.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
We've been through that,
like, 100 times in this class.
Now, what's special about
this network is that remember,
when lambda was less
than one, the network
would respond to the input.
And then what would it do
when we took the input away?
It would decay back to zero.
But this network does
something really special.
This network, you put
an input in and then
take the input away, this
network stays active.
It remembers what the input was.
Whereas, if you have a network
where lambda is less than one,
the network very quickly
forgets what the input was.
All right, what happens when
lambda is greater than one?
So when lambda is greater
than one, this term is now--
this thing inside
the parentheses
is negative, multiplied
by a negative number.
This whole coefficient in front
of the c1 becomes positive.
So we're just going to write
it as lambda minus one.
And so this because positive.
And what does that
solution look like?
Does anyone know
what that looks like?
dc dt equals a positive
number times c.
Nobody?
Are we all just sleepy?
What happens?
So if this is negative, if this
coefficient were negative, dc--
if c is positive, then
dc dt is negative,
and it relaxes to zero, right?
Lets think about
this for a minute.
What happens if this
quantity is positive?
So if c is positive--
cover that up.
If this is positive
and c is positive,
then dc dt is positive.
So that means if c is positive,
it just keeps getting bigger,
right?
And so what happens is you
get exponential growth.
So if we now take an input and
we put it into this network,
where lambda is
greater than one,
you get exponential growth.
And now what happens when
you turn that input off?
Does it go away?
What happens?
draw with their hand
what happens here.
So just look at the equation.
Again, h dot f1 is zero
here, so that's gone.
This is positive.
c is positive.
So what is dc dt?
Good.
It's positive.
And so what is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It keeps growing.
So you can see that
this network also
remembers that it had input.
So this network
also has a memory.
So anytime you have lambda
less than one the network
just-- as soon as
the input goes away,
the network activity
goes to zero,
and it just completely forgets
that it ever had input.
Whereas, as long as lambda is
equal to or greater than one,
then this network remembers
that it had input.
So if lambda is less than
one, then the network
relaxes exponentially back to
zero after the input goes away.
If you have lambda equal to
one, you have an integrator,
and the network
activity persists
after the input goes away.
And if you have
exponential growth,
the network activity
also persists
after the input goes away.
And so that right there
is one of the best
models for short-term
memory in the brain.
The idea that you have
neurons that get input,
become activated, and
then hold that memory
by reactivating themselves and
holding their own activity high
through recurrent excitation.
But that excitation
has to be big enough
to either just barely
maintain the activity
or continue increasing
their activity.
OK, now, that's not
necessarily such a great model
for a memory, right?
Because we can't have
neurons whose activity is
exploding exponentially, right?
So that's not so great.
But it is quite commonly
thought that in neural networks
involved in memory, the lambda
is actually greater than one.
And how would we
rescue this situation?
How would we save our
network from having neurons
that blow up exponentially?
Well, remember, this
was the solution
for a network with
linear neurons.
But neurons in the brain are
not really linear, are they?
They have firing
rates that saturate.
At higher inputs, firing
rates tend [AUDIO OUT]..
Why?
Because sodium channels
become inactivated,
and the neurons can't
respond that fast, right?
All right, this
I've already said.
So we use what are called
saturating non-linearities.
So it's very common
to write down
models in which we can still
have neurons that are--
we can still have them
approximately linear.
So it's quite often to
have neurons that are
linear for small [INAUDIBLE].
They can go plus and
minus, but they saturate
on the plus side or the minus.
So now you can have
an input to a neuron
that activates the neuron.
You can see what happens is you
start activating this neuron.
It keeps activating itself,
even as the input goes away.
But now, what happens
is that activity
starts getting up into the
regime where the neuron can't
fire any faster.
And so the activity becomes
stable at some high value
of firing.
Does that make sense?
And this kind of
neuron, for example,
can remember a plus input, or
it can remember a minus input.
Does that make sense?
So that's how we can
build a simple network
with a neuron that can
remember its previous inputs
with a lambda that's
greater than one.
And this right here,
that basic thing,
is one of the models for
how the hippocampus stores
memories, that you have
hippocampal neurons that
connect to each other
with a lot of recurrent
connections [AUDIO OUT]
in the hippocampus
has a lot of
recurrent connections.
And the idea is that those
neurons activate each other,
but then those neurons saturate
so they can't fire anymore,
and now you can have a stable
memory of some prior input.
And I think we
should stop there.
But there are other
very interesting topics
that we're going to get to
on how these kind of networks
can also make
decisions and how they
can store continuous memories--
not just discrete memories,
plus or minus, on
or off, but can
store a value for a long period
of time using this integrator.
OK, so we'll stop there.